c'était près de chéri alors on y va
vous avez vu ça vous voyez comme elle me
fait confiance
tu serais prête à mourir pour moi vrai
carline je peux vous parler j'aimerais
que vous allez voir les filles manson
comme la peine de mort a été abolie on
ne sait plus quoi en faire
elles vont rester enfermés là l'une à
côté de l'autre 23 heures sur 24 vous
emmène oisel je me présente car l'une
faith elle donne des cours à certaines
détenus d'ici le seul livre que charlie
voulait bien qu'on essaie la bible alors
est ce que ça veut dire que vous avez
l'impression de faire quelque chose de
mal en étudiant avec moi ça me rangerai
bien d'étudier comment vivaient les
femmes de pionnier c'est ce qu'on
apprenait avec sony
du travail de la terre notre suffisance
est ce qu'on essaie de faire tu vois se
débarrasser de nos inhibitions
poursuivre au maximum non vous autres
cycliques et les magnifiques elles
peuvent pas se libérer son est gros ça
fait trois ans qu'elle n'ont plus vu
elle pas que de lui il met les conneries
qu'il a pu leur mettre dans la tête
on va attendre sous la terre on pourra
jouer de la musique et faire l'amour en
attendant la fin de la guerre charlet
disait la vérité
l'apocalypse arrive notre monde et vole
à disparaître
la clé de tout ça c'est un sculpteur ses
pouvoirs qu'une tante dessus d'un lac et
rascal totale là-dessus jamais dit mais
toi qu'est ce que tu en penses s'était
jamais arrivé de te dire que peut-être
helter skelter allait jamais descendre
que charlie se tromper il ya des femmes
dans cette prison qui sont réellement
des victimes
et peut-être que celle là aussi son
effectif merci tu dirais pareil si
c'était à ses enceintes poignardé de 20
coups de couteau c'est qu'il si je
parviens à me recevoir les allemands
fassent ce qu'ils ont fait
seront forcés de vivre advitam avec
cette erreur c'est bien le but de la
prison avant
les filles pourquoi vous avez fait ça il
nous a dit protester charlie est venu
nous parler cette nuit
[Musique]